opening the episode with mike cleaning
11's face like my mom after i've just
conquered a double fudge banana split
with marshmallows and whipped cream but
this touching gesture of face touching
was probably not necessary since there's
a mirror
snog blocking also writing in your own
skip doesn't excuse the fact that a skip
was needed
thing the stranger things kids thought
when they saw us getting ready to send
the show somehow makes its way into this
episode
[Music]
kids the kids resolve all their issues
and get the band back together in the
first five minutes because they've
realized they're stronger as a team and
share a bond forged in the crucible that
is grade school but also it's the
penultimate episode and they need to set
up the finale if you're already inside
the police station this seems a bit
redundant there's something you need to
see you'd better come take a look at
this cliche what happened to her here
being more concerned about eleven's hair
than matthew modine's wasting time
building a model to describe a fenced in
plot of land next to a road with a
building on it and this is the lab right
here lucas that's a can
circling circling
circling still circling
you risked your life
and nancy's to be fair going after the
creature was nancy's idea in the first
place jonathan is a high school kid
meaning he just happens to do less
thinking with his top brain and more
thinking with the brain and his upside
down he probably cares about his brother
and stuff too yeah yeah i'm sure it's
more than that boner thing what is your
name deputy asking for the name of a
person wearing a name tag it looks less
likely these agents are collecting
evidence and more likely they're
planning a sleepover the events of this
season are supposed to have taken place
in 1983 but great american ghost stories
by hans holzer wasn't published until
1990 and the dinosaurs went extinct
about 65 million years ago i'm
definitely sending this ridiculous
ladder placement i get they had to get
the stuff on the other side cleaned up
as well but now they're at a point where
the ladder needs to be moved at least to
the middle of the [ __ ] and wheeler how's
steve gonna get any elbow grease into
his cleaning routine from this angle we
should be out there looking for him
honey we have to trust them okay
stranger things does a pretty great job
of having all the 80s goodness mixed in
with some really interesting character
work so why did ted wheeler have to be a
walking believes the government is
always there to help you idiot father
cliche later
sho thinks it's going to get away with
us not pointing out that dustin is
pointing at the person of color in this
scene while pointing out the person of
color in another scene and this is now a
spider-man sin
i never noticed how closely this part of
the score resembled john carpenter and
now the scene is giving off series
halloween three vibes i don't know
whether to remove us in for the
carpenter-ness of it all or addison
because well you know halloween three so
i'll add five because i'm me hopper
subdues these three intimidatingly
well-dressed agents very quickly and
entirely off-screen so the sin is for
all style and no substance is that my
dress everyone in this show is way too
concerned about eleven's hairstyle and
what she's wearing mike claims to be
explaining the upside down but this
drawing looks more like a person
standing on the horizon next to a gopher
hole i can find them
in the bath show proves the vague posts
were not an original idea formed in the
days of social media and were actually
preceded by vague comments like this
anything about sensory deprivation tanks
specifically how to build one mr clark
appears to have the physical
characteristics of a science teacher but
the show thinks he's a duckduckgo and
for those of you have no idea what i
just said it's the same thing as a
google why are you keeping this
curiosity door locked i'm more curious
as to why dustin or any student has mr
clark's home phone number even for the
80s that's [ __ ] weird you stole that
kitty pool we bought some apples in
admitting to bobbing for apples
admitting to bopping for anything really
using de-icing salt instead of epsom
salt this show is addictive 11's skin
now that we're almost to the end of the
season it appears all characters have
acquired enough xp to activate the squad
boost on all talents enabling everyone
to complete their tasks in record time
just like the saying goes teamwork makes
the nightmare stop hey wait
i'm not gonna snow next week is it worst
case no school i feel like that was
missing something cindy run that back
and hit him with the good stuff hey wait
i'm not gonna snow next week is it worst
case no school
perfect why was it necessary to set this
up in the middle of the gymnasium even
if they had to come to school for
equipment and supplies why the very
middle of the gym and not at least a
little closer to your water source black
voids with wet floors i assume ernest
and hansel duffer killed off barb to
raise the stakes but we weren't watching
the show for stakes we were watching it
for the 80s nostalgia in the triumphant
return of barb i demand justice
i realize you just witnessed something
horrifying that will probably haunt you
for the rest of your life and you'll
never get a good night's sleep again but
i really need you to concentrate on my
son nancy will be able to make new
friends hey so bobby what are you
thinking as far as making the castle
buyer's fort look creepy and the upside
down well i just have one question for
you hank have you ever wondered what it
would look like if swamp thing burped
the worm all over the place burped the
worm bobby you know sprayed the pajama
glue circumjaculated the globe spilled
his brogurt sundae squeeze the okay
bobby i get it just order the mayonnaise
and never speak to me again i guess
because we're in the last few minutes of
the show jonathan is suddenly capable of
sneaking in and out of the police
station unnoticed after that tense
episode i'm glad i can take a break from
this show
nevermind guess i'm clearing my schedule
for the next hour
i asked for mai tai and they brought me
a pina colada and i said no though no
salt for the margarita but it had salt
on it why is he wearing handcuffs you
two suck at peddling meth what happened
to her hair weak follicles leroy i
understand how upsetting this is all i
care about is are you happy with your
hair
hey what's your problem man
even smiling makes my face ache
did i catch a niner in there where
you're calling for my walkie talkie
maybe you're right maybe this is all a
trap it's a trap i have a
science question
do you know anything about sensory
deprivation tanks specifically how to
build one i don't know who the [ __ ] you
are but you have no idea what you're
doing